wanna believe nations today we're going
to talk about how to succeed on social
media and as always if you're watching
the video if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down
you're much more likely to lock it in
for yourself as well
enjoy
[Music]
the room that I have and the thing that
I want to talk to you about today and
the variable of the difference of the
companies that win and leave and the
reason big companies go out of business
like Blockbuster and will work some
things that nature is that the only
thing I do is I mark it in the actual
thing year we live in what I'm concerned
about when I look at the behavior online
of 99 percent of this room and when I
say this room let's throw everybody into
it the fortune 500 companies I work with
all the startups 99% of people are
marketing like it's 2008 2004 2002 1997
1994 and that my friends is the
disconnect the reason most people are
giving up dollars and aren't relevant is
they're not storytelling in the year
that we actually live in because that
takes storytelling where people's
attention is the number one thing that
connects every single person in this
room is we're all battling for
somebody's attention before you can tell
me how great you are and how my life is
going to be so legit if I get into this
or why it's so delicious or way
healthier before you tell me all that
stuff you need to get my attention the
Internet is the gateway drug to
one-on-one relationships let me say it
again because I know there's a lot of
old-school folks in here I listen I'm an
old school folk there's a lot of old
school folks that say yeah there's new
stuff and it's sad and everybody's on
their phone and this internet stuff but
we're a business that's built on
one-on-one relationships let me tell you
something I've scaled the kind of
one-on-one relationships what this thing
right here and if you do not understand
that engagement online is the gateway to
one-on-one relationships in our world
today you are missing the culture shift
we're living in
whoo
I think by far the biggest tip I can
give you is to post more frequently many
brands assume they should only post once
or twice a day on Facebook or Twitter
and I think that's just wrong my twitter
account is like 75 to 80 posts per day
Google Plus s5 Facebook has 5 so lets
you know it's 80 hundred posts a day and
if my assumption is that not everybody
who's interested in my content is awake
at the same time and you can if they are
awake at the same time they may have
different consumption habits
some people read in the morning some
people in London some people at night so
yes you will when you post more and more
you'll get people complaining that
you're posted too much your spammer you
know bla bla bla but I could tell you
for example a Twitter
I literally repeat my tweets 3 times 8
hours apart and I track it with a bitly
link and I can tell you the first time I
tweet I get eggs click second time I get
X in the third time I get X so you can
either have X clicks or 3x clicks and
you know my attitude is okay so some
people are upset with that that's just
the cost of doing business that the goal
of social media is not to not piss off
anybody the Kolo social media is and
create a very marketing and powerful
platform so that's my number one tip to
brands using social media to get a big
following you have to read everyday you
know I wake up in the morning personally
and I read I read inspiring things I'll
read some Emerson I'll read some a lot
of philosophy about life I'll read some
narratives or biographies of people who
inspire me I get my mind in the morning
whether it's on poetry or philosophy or
political figure something that inspires
me to be thinking in a bigger way that's
what I do every day and I think it
you're you're following ultimately comes
from how big your thinking is you know
if you're just micromanaging and living
in one little world as much as they want
to teach you to be niche marketer now we
want you to be a thought leader there's
a big difference are you a niche
marketer or your thought leader and I
choose thought leadership and I think
it's valuable I think it's important for
you to be broadening you
your own mindset your own philosophy
about life or business or career or
whatever it is your topic is and be
broadening that by reading more in that
area because reading more will make you
more creative and you I know you know
readers or leaders leaders are readers
and so you got to be reading things that
digest in your mind that oddly suddenly
will come out in a creative thought or a
creative act and it's those creative
thoughts and acts get you followed on
line the real funny thing to me in the
world right now is that everybody's
foolish right and what I mean by that is
when you look at people tweeting or
facebooking they're trying to disguise
their act by being witty right meanwhile
the one thing I know more than anything
is that our collective [ __ ] radars
today compared to 15 years ago are
dramatically better and the kids they're
both radars are excelling they just
think that they just know it right so
what I've been testing a lot of and
believe a lot of value in is jab jab jab
right hook give people value and funny
stories give them an animated gif that
just makes them laugh right that just
makes say happy Monday it's fine you
don't need a business objective for
every piece of creative because we live
in a world now where it's not just about
campaigns where you do two or three and
you spend all your money you live in a
world where we're doing it every day a
lot of it and so we have the freedom the
creative freedom to actually act human
and bring a little value to them bring
value bring down you bring value respond
engage brings value make it funny make
it newsworthy and then let's all become
grown-ups once and for all and recognize
you can ask for the business if we're
just authentic about it a funny thing
happens when you give a load of value up
front you guilt people into buying
and so what give valium give value act
human do the right thing answer be there
for them have good everybody on like
Twitter everybody can see it be funny on
Twitter like funny is like the one
characteristic that works up everything
works on Twitter it's a human platform
it the problem is most people don't want
to be self-deprecating or or have
empathy or be kind like there's not that
many and nobody wants to put it out
there they think they want to put out
something that gets retweeted how about
we listen instead of talk people like
that think about the friend that you
would rather call instead of friend that
always calls you and then think about
who you want to hang out with right and
so we have to act human we have to bring
value and then you say value value value
and then you say I'm a book right and
that kind of the science you know boxing
is known as a sweet science that's why I
use this metaphor for titles how I think
I'm spending all my time and energy and
I highly recommend whatever energy
you're spending on this you spend more
because the attention the eyes the ears
of our consumers they're clearly going
in these places they're clearly going in
these places and if we do not figure out
the art and the science of how to
actually storytelling them not use them
as just distribution realize how stupid
it is to use the same picture on
Instagram Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
realize that understand there's a real
science in this a real storytelling
battle going on right now in these
platforms and understanding that you as
an individual act differently when you
go into a boardroom in a business
meeting than you would when you go with
your girls to Las Vegas for the weekend
then when you would when you go out with
your boyfriend you're still the same
person but the context of the room
changes the way you story go I think
that there are a few things to look at
when you're trying to master safe social
media and that is social media
during rod and you should be specific
and choosing the one that wore two tools
to focus on and by that I mean if you
have a toolkit to be a good carpenter
folks from one tool at a time
and similarly I wouldn't try to become
an expert at Facebook Twitter Linkedin
tumblr WordPress all simultaneously
choose one dependent on the format where
you feel most effective and that you
enjoy because you'll need that video to
fuel you through all the learning curve
and then focus on that in my particular
case I use the blog which is WordPress
based and I focused on typically 500 to
1500 word peaches developed that as my
heart a very important concept that was
my my Grand Central Station and if I get
anything on say Facebook or Twitter it
either was to to broadcast things I find
interest or value my readers or to bring
them to content that was on the blog and
that was the center of the heartbeat the
focus on one thing at a time and I think
in life as in social media you can have
it all and you just can't have it all at
the same time primary lesson that's hard
for me to get into people's brains who
want to learn about business or
improving their financial situation it
you go straight to the top well most
people do is they find the front like if
you want to grow your Instagram you find
a friend who has a thousand more
Instagram followers and you're like oh
let me get a tip from them forget that
go straight to the top who has the most
Taylor Swift has 50 points seven mints
million inch to followers it takes the
same amount of time and day to learn
from Taylor Swift Instagram as it does
you know from your brothers or your
uncles or something like that and I
think the reason and this applies not
just if to growing your social media
following I'll talk about that in a
second some things that I've learned to
grow social following Pitt this applies
to all areas in life you want to learn
how to play basketball go watch old
Michael Jordan videos you want to learn
how to lift weights go watch some old
arm forcing yourself some Lee Haney
stuff you want to learn to be healthy
find somebody who's a you know
supermodel or something I got a friend
he's one of the top male models in the
world dude has like an eight-pack
hang out with him you go straight to the
top don't be intimidated and don't sell
yourself short back to the subject of
growing social media following to me
nowadays it's all about a couple
things it's all about lifestyle
marketing and lifestyle growth you know
people want people ask me ty you got
this big house like why don't you get
you afford a selfie stick or a tripod
well I actually do have a tripod right
there
but a lot of things people engage better
I've tested it people want to know it's
like having a face-to-face conversation
so make sure social media is not too
stiff and stuffy you know make sure like
the office TV show some of you saw I
know Dwight Schrute Rainn Wilson he was
here at the house I don't know week or
two ago and we're talking about how the
office they would use these cameras
which made it feel like you were in the
actual office with Steve Carell and and
you know Dwight Schrute and all these
funny guys and so it up their ratings it
was they did 202 episodes so whether
it's TV whether it's Instagram even your
video even your entrepreneurial growth
can be fueled by this reality slash
lifestyle branding so I mean you know I
got YouTube videos I've done a lot of
views sixty million views that were done
like this and how was that how did I
kind of come to that realization well it
was by following people straight to the
top even if you look at a lot of these
big people whether it's a you know
Taylor Swift or ariana grande has a big
following and you look at the engagement
of which pictures in which videos get
the most engagement on our social you
get information gathering sessions you
sit there you stare at it you're like
wait a sec that picture that's all
formal with the photographer and all
stiff
that one got you know 50,000 likes and
this one where it's just like her like
well the cameras going light was up that
one did 75,000 boom clue reveal clue
reveals the answer right there to you so
so I was a couple quick spots on social
media that I wanted to share how to have
success number one is you have to define
your outcome it's important to know what
you want out of it are you trying to
build a personal brain are you trying to
sell your product or service are you
trying to just have a form of escape
just to get away from your busy life and
you want to connect with your friends
understanding why you're on the platform
will help you devise a strategy
to win number two is find your voice
it's really important that you
understand that there is nobody else
like you there's a lot of other people
out there they have their own opinions
their own voices but you're not going to
succeed by just being a copy of somebody
else your ultimate success will come by
you finding your own voice and putting
out content that you resonate with that
other people aren't seeing those exact
same things and so at the beginning this
is hard at the beginning you don't know
what your voice is at the beginning
you're still trying to figure it all out
and so I think it's actually okay to
copy people at the start it's okay to
copy somebody style of making videos or
making tweaks are making Instagram
pictures it's okay to copy and in that
process you learn about yourself you
need to understand though that your
ultimate success won't come by copying
somebody else you will never be
massively successful by just being a
junior version of somebody else so a lot
of people copy my video styles as an
example they'll make their own top ten
rules of their own versions of what I'm
doing and it's okay it doesn't bother me
they're never going to have the success
that I'm having if they're just copying
me but what it allows you to do by
copying those people is then see hmm
I like that I like what Evans doing I
like what Gary's doing I like what Jimmy
is doing I like what Susan is doing but
I want to twist it up a little bit
that's where you're going to have
success when you take what is working
for somebody else and then you twist it
and add some flavor to it that only you
can add because you can never out Evan
Evan and I can never out you you so go
being you that's how you're going to win
you need to find your voice and number
three is be prolific it's important that
if you are trying to achieve a real
outcome we were trying to build a brand
you're trying to sell products that you
are prolific in the creation of the
content you're not going to get really
great at it if you're doing something
once a week you just not going to get
really good at it try learning anything
once a week without practicing in
between you're never going to get really
good at it if you're trying to pick up
salsa dancing or you want to learn
Spanish you want to play the piano if
you're only doing it once a week you're
never going to get really really
really good at it you need to be more
prolific the quantity leads to the
quality the practice leads to you
getting good at something and so back to
number one if you have a goal if you
have a business objective and this is
important to you then you have success
with it then you need to dedicate time
for you to learn it to get good at it to
practice to practice the practice to be
prolific so that you can find your voice
and create content that really touches
people
so those are my thoughts on social media
those are some of the thoughts of the
experts in the field I made this video
because Siddharth weeper asked me to so
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of believe life
leave it down in the comments and I'll
see what I can do
I'm also curious to figure out what did
you like most about this video what left
me going to immediately apply to your
life to your business after watching
this and why are you on social what is
your outcome what is your objective are
you doing it for personal development to
try to learn are you trying to build a
brand and sell product is it just an
escape from your busy life you want to
be entertained super curious to figure
that out leave in the comments I'm going
to join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick show - Neil Marley thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and posting that
review on your Facebook page I really
really really appreciate it and I hope
that it's had a good impact on your life
so thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love
have an amazing day I'll see you soon
it's just not how was your wife me being
on the cover Vick great lesson you know
to me the answer is it's got to be
something a lot of impression for the
wareness type that may get them into the
rabbit hole of me they saw me at the
airport they saw the ink they Google me
they read my Wikipedia they follow me on
Twitter seven days later I put out a
good SlideShare nine days later I asked
them to buy the book from a right hook
on Twitter they buy it
ROI to Inc but how you're going to
quantify that is insanity and so I think
social media has been asked to create an
ro line that every other medium hasn't
or hasn't since they didn't accept it
right television went through this and
it's a season six wait a minute this TV
thing what's the ROI we know what radio
and print does so it's the same old game
is at historic I mean we can be having
this meeting I wish I was older and I
wish that I was on the scene back in
ninety five six seven when I talked
about e-commerce because all the same
questions how are you going to compete
with Walmart and Kmart and JC Penney's
and Barnes and Nobles and borders and
Waldenbooks houses Amazon's been going
to compete I was laughing at people to
the notion and clearly that's played out
over the last two decades I think we'll
look back at what's the art the ROI of
anything that gets in front of a
consumer where they actually spend their
time here's where I know everybody who's
watching right now they do this for a
living and if you don't know how to get
into this screen and story tell about
what you do for a living you're out
social networks control an enormous
percentage of that consumption if you
don't have story tell in a stream
economy in 2014 I think you're really
playing Russian roulette with your
advertising dollars you're going to have
people around you in your organization
and/or you're going to get e-mails back
saying oh this doesn't work or this is a
waste of time okay
you're also going to have people tell
you back off okay this is not wanted or
don't spam me or you sent me the wrong I
don't need this why did you send this to
me this is exactly what happens to all
people that are trying to get attention
when you get attention at the right
level the first thing that's going to
happen to you is you're going
criticism you want to push through the
criticism until you get admiration you
want to push through more it's not any
different Facebook Twitter YouTube
social media is no different than me
knocking on a door saying hey I want to
show you a product you're going to have
people slam the door in your face the
next question goes dude they're going to
say get out of my neighborhood what are
you doing here if you stop because of
this suppression this stop on you if you
stop because people are asking you to
stop you're done so the same thing
happens with social media look when you
tweet or when you put an entry into
Facebook the way to take that and make
it unique okay and not spammy and not
bother people is to personalize it so
consider the people that you've been
trying to sell products to not just your
friends let's say there was a plumber
you're trying to sell a truck to you
would want to email the plumber and say
mr. plumber I just got a hold of a site
of a sales trainer that can increase
your sales in your business mr. plumber
and I wanted to make sure you have the
information there I thought of you when
I saw this and by the way I could win
$10,000 and soak it in the any of your
employees as well as getting hooked up
with a guy that can increase your sales
in this economy I thought of you so you
got to personalize it so that it's not
spammy you can't just keep using that
one message we sent you yesterday which
was I can win $10,000 and so can you
look at spammy that's why people saying
it's spammy you have to personalize it
do this with heart you can't survive
doing this if your art isn't real if
your heart isn't in the work because you
won't get up in the morning be motivated
for it you you won't be excited about it
you have to have at the base of all that
you're posting if if people can tell
that you care you'll be followed if
people can tell that you care about
values and humanity and the philosophy
of living a good life and taking care of
other people respecting other people
you'll be followed you could become a
caustic hater and maybe it'll get gather
a couple people but you're never going
to get millions of people and if you do
you'll burn
your soul because nobody wants to live a
life where they're just criticizing and
being a jerk be the positive thought
leader in whatever you do be the most
caring be the most consistent be the
person who shows up and if you'll just
show up every day with intention to
capture one unique moment one unique
lesson one unique story when you need to
quote one unique picture when you need
video whatever it is for you and your
favorite medium capture one thing every
single day you'll be fully energized
with your life because life won't just
be work anymore its arms